just a few weeks after hitting us with
summer game fest and its many world
premieres jeff keeley is back to host
opening night live this event kicks off
the annual european gaming convention
gamescom and jeff has already teased 30
plus games will be shown off opening
night live 2022 will be the first live
in person opening night live
presentation since 2019 following two
years of online only live streams
tickets are available for those
attending gamescom in cologne germany
however for those of us that can't make
the trip to germany there's still an
option to watch it on one of the
expensive screens we all own here's how
gamescom opening night live 2022 will be
available right here on gamespot's
youtube and twitch channel the stream
begins tuesday august 23rd at 11 a.m
pacific time 2 p.m eastern and according
to jeff the stream will run about 2
hours so make sure you have plenty of
snacks and plenty of water you don't
want to be dehydrated when your next
favorite game gets announced previous
opening night lives have also featured
announcements during a half hour
pre-show but at the time of this
recording a similar start has yet to be
confirmed for this year's event however
we will be doing our own pre and post
show to chat about the biggest
announcements and the good news is that
we already know a small list of what you
can expect to see at opening night live
for starters we'll be getting brand new
gameplay for the kalista protocol a new
survival horror game led by dead space
creator glenn schofield so fans of those
games will most definitely love this the
kalista protocol is set in a prison
called black iron located on one of
jupiter's moons callisto protagonist
jacob lee has found himself trapped as
mutated humans begin taking over and
murdering other inmates sounds perfect
for a scaredy cat like me and speaking
of games that i'll probably never play
we'll also get a new look at the outlast
trials another survival horror game that
you can play with up to 4 friends in the
much less scary department we'll be
getting new looks at two games that are
sure to be incredibly hilarious goat
simulator 3 and high on life despite the
number 3 in its title goat sim 3 is
actually the second in the franchise and
the game will once again let you loose
in a sandbox to cause all types of chaos
as a goat meanwhile high on life the
newest title from rick and morty
co-creator justin roiland is an
action-adventure metroidvania
first-person shooter that is by far my
most anticipated out of this confirmed
list jeff also revealed we'll be getting
a new look at the recently delayed
hogwarts legacy as well as the game that
refuses to settle for a delay sonic
frontiers and if you're at gamescom then
you can try out sonic frontiers for
yourself because it's playable at the
show the last two that we know of at the
moment are returned to monkey island and
a brand new sci-fi ip from subnautica
developer unknown worlds entertainment
however i'm sure jeff is going to
continue to tease games as the event
draws closer so make sure to check his
twitter account every now and then if
you want to stay immersed in all things
opening night live and we'll keep a
running list here on gamespot for
comparison's sake last year's opening
night live event included the reveal of
the new saints row and marvel's midnight
suns as well as gameplay for call of
duty vanguard's campaign and death
stranding director's cut leave a comment
with your craziest world premiere
announcement predictions and i might pin
the best one and don't forget to come
back to gamespot on tuesday to watch the
stream
you